hello I am Jessie Maley and I'm Ben
Barnes and I'm Daisy head Lewis tan here
I'm Anna Leon Brophy and I'm Patrick
Gibson and we're here to play a game of
who's who I'm so sorry God has Amazon
said alive
is that it great I just did it and I'm
Patrick Gibson and we're here to play
Who's Who on BuzzFeed
[Music]
no I don't know I don't think I'm very
much like Alina darling you shine
a darling stop I think she's necessarily
infused with more of you than to
characters are you know what in my mind
I think the people who are most like
their characters are Anna and Lewis you
know sometimes they do the most iconic
like and it does her feisty Tamar thing
and then Lewis is always talking about
food and poetry and spirituality those
two honestly I feel like they're casting
is
pretty cool it's pretty cute yeah
[Music]
well I guess Ben's quite sweet Lucas oh
yeah yeah that's true yeah that's a
great one I mean if I don't if I don't
say if I don't say me I'm a psycho so I
need to be kind yeah you are nothing
like General character however you know
you always got to try and find little
kind of pieces of humanity that you do
understand you know that you can kind of
like sew in there but there are many
more layers deep down in this character
than they would be in others
[Music]
people
I feel like pep yeah maybe Danny's
pretty good that's good yeah oh probably
Jesse probably Jesse Yeah so you know
the books really really well I feel like
I've I'm now it's all very mixed up in
my mind that's true you would win on the
show
[Music]
[Laughter]
there was that scene right at the end
when we were getting on the hummingbird
and you and Archie just could not oh
yeah you just and you get both of you
kept me oh sorry sorry
as well when in the script it made like
perfect sense but I have a line where
I'm like what's happening and Archie's
line is I don't know
I think yeah I would say actually both
of these two but also Louis kit as well
yeah as well everyone is physically
pretty capable like Archie doing you
know he came late in the season didn't
he and he had one afternoon to learn all
his choreography for his first fight
scene yeah he did it yeah we moved quite
quick so we only really get a few
there was some obviously
one take wonders the twins over here
we had a cool fight scene yeah together
when we're fighting two as one the twins
for the first time on the boat in the
air yeah that was great tick tick tick
tick
[Music]
Archie yeah yeah are just good with
memes half of them are like football
yeah they're Chelsea related
daily daily memes I'm not very okay with
the memes let me down the picture with
writing on it yeah
yeah how many points do I get for
knowing what I mean is
[Music]
have you heard those high notes Alistair
Alistair and kit I actually copy as soon
as it becomes karaoke I become instantly
very shy I've done karaoke in many many
years because I panic at what songs to
pick and I just choose nothing and drink
whiskey in the corner so not me for
karaoke I need a full band
kit did hop on stage and Crush karaoke a
few times kid and Alistair right yeah
they set an entire Club on fire once
with an uptown Funk performance that
literally had the whole place like we're
like we're watching a concert
[Music]
yeah if anyone's gonna let the side down
it will probably be partying listen I'll
take it I mean yeah I do have a lot of
secret I have a lot of secrets that I'm
trying to you know that I've got a key
there's the spoilers it's a mess like I
really can't say anything
I just can't control what comes out of
my mouth I've let some stuff slip but it
wasn't an accident
you're just you're just stirring them
putty maybe do you think everyone's
quite good actually at
um being well behaved and not saying too
much apart from maybe me I feel like I I
hear it coming and I'm like
and I kept saying that in that last
episode of the second season that
okay
[Music]
over there this little sleep described
things probably I've got so many
pictures of her sleeping under tables oh
I just like to hide it's the safest
place to have enough in case there's an
earthquake
meteor Jesse yeah oh no no it's Joanna
oh
yeah
Incredible Gift she has just
out out like a light
[Music]
well you know you of course you I don't
even go straight but that's the thing me
and Kate are the social set Jesse will
throw the party kit we'll start the
dancing what happens in Budapest stays
in Budapest what happens after midnight
Ben doesn't know because he's gotten
home to sleep
Jesse had some great Parts yes he had
some really good parties you had some
good ones we said that we were having
this party where we were all dressing as
each other and Danny was like you know
and like Kalan you gotta meet her that's
who you drew out of the heart and
everyone else is going to be all these
different people so Callahan pulls up
dressed as a pizza to a party where
we've all dressed as Kalahari
[Music]
yeah but not but you'd have brought your
own snacks
to come in with a bunch of Tupperware
Tupperware chaos in your trailer apart
from when you're in the scene I don't
think
[Laughter]
she figured something out with the chef
too she was getting meals that weren't
on the normal menu she knows how to live
Paddy Paddy yeah or Lewis he wouldn't
pack a bag right Paddy and Lewis yeah
together would be missing they'd be off
hanging off a mountain somewhere in
another dimension maybe a daisy thing
Daisy yes sneaky Daisy just sneakers
what's in it foreign
character she could probably she's very
climbing I feel like she could be quite
a good cat burglar yeah I just want to
see her in the outfit I think we've all
got it in us I think it's gonna be
Freddy yeah yeah yeah although maybe not
in real life
[Music]
I think probably me I've got so many so
many selfies like in character I think I
have one I know I don't think I've ever
seen I can't even imagine you taking
yourself do you even know how yeah
cool with you and you're like why are
you hauling like an old woman
a lot of us like to take photos of each
other or other people Lewis takes some
great photos yeah and so did Freddie we
had some uh Great Moments brought some
nice film cameras on set and took some
beautiful portraits of each other yeah
but selfie's not so much selfies not so
much
[Music]
I don't know
yeah I think I did too yeah yeah that
one out I think Archie's a big softie
yeah not on the last day just everyday
this is called lunch
bye BuzzFeed thanks for watching don't
forget to check out Shadow and bone on
Netflix
I know
[Music]